it was literally everywhere but the
toilet I worked at a Victoria's Secret
throughout college one time there's like
very sweet old lady came into the store
and like had an accident and just like
pooped on the floor and my manager had
to clean it up and Spencer Pratt came in
once so I got a job at the express of
the Delano mall and I keep getting
assigned to the Jean wall it's like a
whole method to it you have to like fold
it at the reason them so I'm folding and
I overhear my coworker compliment my
folding job to my manager and I overhear
a manager respond well you know those
Asians are really good at origami I used
to work at a candle shop in Sydney and
one day I went to open the store as I
normally would and underneath the door
was this little love heart-shaped USB
and a note so I picked it up and it said
to the girl with the hat and it was a
love letter and then and I put the USB
in and it was a page a hobby song a
perfect day and I never found out who it
was so in high school I worked at
Blockbuster which makes me seem really
old but it wasn't that long ago and this
guy would call all the time asking for
porn and we could tell it was the same
guy most the time we would just have to
say I'm sorry sir this is a family store
and his response would be what about
this family of sperm and then he would
hang up the store was huge and our
bathrooms are in the back of the store
and like there was like this wafting
smell growing and we'd gotten so many
complaints from customers they were like
okay let's see what this novel is about
and it was like that movie The Shining
where they there's so much blood all
over the place we'll just replace all
the redness with brown like chunky poo
my manager at Abercrombie was a woman
who I think was she seemed to twenty
years older than me she was probably
three years older than me and the most
distinct thing I remember happening is
one day I was eating an apple and she
said what does that taste like
and I said an apple and she said yeah
I've never had one she was later
arrested I believe
or stealing thousands of dollars worth
of clothes for her nephews
[Music]